happy halloween right need something
that won't spook your loved ones and be
done in just 10 minutes this is ramsey
in 10.
[Music]
now let's be honest cheese and toast is
one of my all-time favorite snacks but
today i'm taking the cheese on toast the
basic cheese and toast to a whole new
level because this is a bacon
cauliflower cheese on toast now please
watch closely because i promise you
you're going to love it right oscar the
ingredients clearly cauliflower
beautiful stunning vegetable
bits of bacon some really rich
stunning mature cheddar cheese and
finished with parmesan double cream
cream cheese salt pepper and this baby
here a beautiful
sourdough bread
right let's have 10 minutes on the clock
please
right cheese on toast in 10 minutes but
with a difference right get your bread
you know when you start toasting bread
okay never go too thin
okay get it really nice and thick
because you want to taste that beautiful
sauvo bread
from there
turn that on
and literally
in to the oven
and get that toasting
now the secret behind any great
toast and cheese
is just toasting that bread once making
sure that we do not
get that bread soggy
so the bacon
again i'm using a really nice light sort
of back bacon
and it's smoked okay that's gonna be
a really nice sort of
smoky flavor across
the sort of cauliflower
cheese and bacon a touch of oil just a
touch okay whack up the gas
now from there drop in
these little crispy
bacon lardons and what we'll do here in
this pan is sort of almost make
it's like a sort of flourless roux
okay a nice cheesy
smoky flavor that sits beautifully on
the toast
and talk about toast
and
boom
touch more
check that toast now
as that bacon's getting crispy get your
paring knife and just go around
and these little sort of
trees are called florets and so the
secret here
is literally just to
get the florets
and cut them in half
and the big ones into quarter
what we're going to do now is sort of
lightly toast these
with the bacon okay
in
now you'll be surprised
how quick these cauliflower
florets cook
but just just take a look in there
oscar please pan down my man pan down
look at that beautiful
really beautiful
now
a touch of salt
and a touch of pepper
get some color on that bacon but look
give that a little toss so that nice
smoky bacon flavor
is now permeating across
the cauliflower cauliflower
sort of toasted like this
in that bacon fat with a little bit of
butter lightly smoked is delicious
butter goes in now
that stops it
from burning but look what's happening
to the cauliflower
now we start the magic now we start the
sort of
the cauliflower and cheese richness
a teaspoon of smoked paprika in there
okay that's going to give it some
richness
and a little kick and spice
in
from there
some heat
a tablespoon of mustard
english mustard okay
and then
roll that round but look what's
happening to that cauliflower
we've got the heat in the pan
in goes the cream cheese
generous
in goes the double cream
and this is when we start to make that
beautiful
cheese sauce
now bring that up to the boil
as it's boiling
away get your rich
cheddar cheese
and i like grating it on the thick side
because it's crumbly and it's delicious
and i want that really nice rich flavor
in there but look what's happening in
that pan
all that beautiful goodness
and this cheese
literally
crumbles
and over now
bring that together okay
gas down
and just bring that together when i say
bring that together give it a light toss
and look we've got this nice sort of
cauliflower smoky bacon flavored
mixture
now for my toast
gas goes off
now toast
turn that around
because what i'd like
is to make sure that i've got a nice
crisp base and the top i want it a
little bit sort of soggy
get your spoon
and generously
start spooning that on
and covering
five minutes
halfway
now
do not
waste any of this
that smoked paprika
gives it that really nice
flavor
slightly spicy
but it's a sweet spice it's not a
sharp hot spice
first one done
now
it's so nice to see
all that coming together and you want it
sort of
slightly loose
but
feel
those slices of bread
this is a great pick-me-up when you sort
of can't decide between lunch you can't
decide between dinner
and you're sort of stuck in the middle
this is the perfect
dish now those bake
bits so good
get your
parmesan
and literally
over the top i want to sort of
cover that now
with your parmesan quite thick i want
this nice coat
okay
of cheese on top
and the smell of that is amazing part
that up okay
anything falls off pile it up don't
waste those bits
on and on and then look finally before
it goes back into the grill some crushed
black pepper really important
and season that cheese okay
a little touch of salt
and now she's ready
to go back in the oven time please
man
right under the grill
i want that grill sort of bubbling
that cheese on top now what do we do to
get this thing
a little lighter how do we get that
thing just a little bit more sort of
flavoursome
fresh chives
that gives a nice light
onion flavor
that we're just going to sort of
sprinkle on top
of that cheese
on toast
now
we've all had teasing toast many times
grilled cheese but this cauliflower and
bacon edition especially that smoked
paprika honestly is incredible
now with the chives i like to mix a bit
of salt and pepper
no one ever seasons their chives i do
and so it just puts that really nice
finish on there
and then
finally
time please two minutes two minutes
now
look at that
that is bubbling it's bubbling get those
season chives be heavy on the chives
you'll see why because it sort of cuts
through that richness but gives it that
really nice lift of that nice sweet
gentle onion flavor and with the bacon
the cauliflower
trust me
that
is to die for
beautiful one
and this one
second one
and that my friend
has to be
the most delicious
cauliflower bacon cheese on toast in
under
10 minutes
boom
time please
one minute and 15 seconds
shut the front door
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsey and
ten cookbook inspired by this series and
trust me you're gonna come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck